quand la victime se transforme en
bourreau c'est la triste affaire qui
étaient jugés depuis deux jours devant
la cour d'assises d'indre et loire en
octobre 2015 à saint laurent en gâtine
au petit jour un plombier tir au fusil
de chasse sur deux hommes qui sont en
train de cambrioler son véhicule
professionnel l'un deux est touché et
reste paralysé des membres inférieurs
l'auteur des coups de feu risquait 15
ans de prison l'avocate générale a
requis 3 au retour sur ces deux jours de
procès avec sa malle colin
à aucun moment je n'ai voulu les toucher
juste les faire fuir la voix calme et le
ton posé l'accusé évoque un gâchis une
réaction de peur et de colère ce 22
octobre 2015 il est 5 heures 10 du matin
lorsque dans le silence de la nuit il
entend du bruit devant chez lui à saint
laurent en gâtine il voit alors à
l'arrière de son fourgon deux
silhouettes s'activer à la lumière de
lampes torches un énième vol pour ce
plombier à son compte également chasseur
est réputé bon tireur il saisi son fusil
et des munitions aux brenneke pour gros
gibier sans sommation il tire une
première fois en l'air les deux
individus prennent la fuite dans leur
voiture tous feux éteints l'accusé tir
alors une seconde fois à 45 mètres de
distance la balle de gros calibre
traverse la carrosserie du véhicule le
siège et le dos du passager touché à la
moelle épinière celui ci est désormais
paraplégique toute la question pour les
jurés lors de ces deux jours d'audience
l'accusé at il volontairement tiré en
direction de la voiture ce qu'indiquent
les expertises balistiques un tir
horizontale à hauteur d'homme je ne me
l'expliqué pas dit l'accusé il est
présenté comme quelqu'un d'impulsif deux
sanguins et à ce moment là alors déprimé
et en difficulté financière votre geste
est grave l'on ne se rend pas justice
seule avec un fusil pour une caisse à
outils lui dit l'avocate générale
prenant en compte son insertion sociale
elle requiert trois ans de prison ferme
dont deux envisageable avec un bracelet
électronique
le jugement doit être rendu dans la
soirée